Black Panther gave us a spectacular big-screen
introduction to Wakanda with a politically-charged
and emotional thriller that has important
implications for the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm discussing the thrilling ending
to Black Panther and what it all means for
future Marvel movies.
In case you don't know already, I do regular
videos about superhero movies, and I'm currently
also running a Black Panther giveaway.
For a chance to win, be sure to subscribe
and leave a comment below about the movie.
Obviously spoilers ahead, so take care if
you haven't seen Black Panther yet.
There are a number of themes woven into Black
Panther that get some resolution by the end
of the movie, but let's start with the very
final scene before the credits, which is when
T'Challa and Shuri visit the basketball court
and apartment block in Oakland where the movie's
opening flashback scene was set.
There's an interesting symmetry between the
beginning and the end of the film which demonstrates
T'Challa has made a concrete decision to lead
a positive change in the world and correct
the wrongs committed by his father T'Chaka
and Zuri, aka James, back in 1992, when they
confronted T'Chaka's brother about helping
Klaue steal vibranium.
It was in Oakland where T'Chaka killed his
brother N'Jobu.
Though he did this to save Zuri, his actions
sowed the seeds of anger and resentment in
Prince N'Jobu's son Erik, aka Killmonger,
when they chose to abandon him rather than
take care of him.
Unlike his father, T'Challa is determined
to stop operating in secret and he openly
lands his Royal Talon Fighter on the basketball
court.
Both in this scene and the subsequent mid-credits
scene, T'Challa proves that he's ready to
reveal the truth about Wakanda.
He also wants Wakanda to have a positive impact
on the world by converting the apartment block,
which was the location of the tragedy in the
flashback scene, as well as the buildings
either side of it, into a Wakandan outreach
centre, and he appoints Nakia as head of social
outreach while Shuri will spear-head a science
exchange.
Of course, it's just coincidence, but given
that Sterling K. Brown plays N'Jobu, this
moment made me think of the TV drama This
Is Us and how Brown's character Randall buys
the run-down building where his father had
lived so he could improve life for everyone
living there.
That final Oakland scene also shows the culmination
of T'Challa's arc in the movie by proving
that he could be king and still be a good
man.
If you're wondering what I mean by this, remember
when T'Challa visited his father on the ancestral
plane after ingesting the Heart-Shaped Herb
for the first time?
Well, T'Chaka told his son, "You're a good
man, with a good heart.
And it's hard for a good man to be king."
T'Challa later learned what his father meant
by this when Zuri revealed how he'd helped
T'Chaka hide the truth about what happened
to N'Jobu and his son Erik.
Finally, during their second meeting on the
ancestral plane, T'Chaka admitted to his son
that he'd chosen Wakanda and its people over
his nephew.
And that lie about the events in Oakland,
that truth which T'Chaka chose to bury for
many years actually, as T'Challa puts it,
ended up creating a monster in the form of
Killmonger.
These moments of revelation in Black Panther
reminded me of Thor: Ragnarok – spoiler
alert if you've not seen it – because we
discovered in that film that Odin had hidden
his daughter Hela and her role in violently
conquering the Nine Realms.
Each of these stories involves concealing
both the existence of relatives – T'Challa's
cousin and Thor's sister – and the violence
sometimes used to maintain seemingly benevolent
rule.
And of course, in both stories, it's the sons
who are left dealing with the damage caused
by their fathers' actions.
T'Challa is appalled by what T'Chaka did and
takes Nakia's advice not to let his father's
mistakes define him.
As she said, "you get to decide what kind
of king you are going to be."
And that's exactly what T'Challa does when
he refuses to stay with his father in the
ancestral plane the second time they meet
there.
Instead of joining his ancestors, T'Challa
chooses to return to Wakanda and prove he
can be a good man and a good king by affecting
real change in the world, sharing his nation's
resources and technology for the betterment
of others.
By the end of the film, T'Challa's eyes have
been opened by both Nakia, who told him she
had "seen too many in need to turn a blind
eye" any longer, and also by the events that
led Erik on the path to become Killmonger.
Killmonger's death is another crucial moment
in Black Panther.
In keeping with his beliefs, he preferred
to die than be imprisoned, and his death in
front of the Wakandan sunset was an emotional
link back to the words he shared with his
father about Wakandan sunsets being the most
beautiful in the world.
In addition to the symmetry between the film's
opening and closing scenes in Oakland, there's
also a certain symmetry around the fates of
Killmonger and his father N'Jobu, each of
whom died in complicated circumstances at
the hands of a relative.
T'Chaka had wanted his brother to face Wakanda's
council for his crimes, but ended up killing
him to save Zuri.
While T'Challa was defending himself from
Killmonger and Wakanda from his rule, but
ultimately offered his cousin the healing
power of Wakandan technology.
As the movie's main antagonist, Killmonger's
world view was very much in opposition to
Black Panther's outlook, but then the two
men had very different upbringings.
T'Challa was raised in Wakanda, which due
to the vibranium meteorite, was able to isolate
itself from the world and was therefore never
subject to the colonialism experienced by
their African neighbours.
On the other hand, in many ways, Killmonger
represents the African experience as a result
of colonialism, slavery and racism.
Erik was brought up in Oakland, which is both
the birthplace of the film's director Ryan
Coogler and the city where, in 1966, the real-life
Black Panther Party began with a focus on
combating police brutality against the black
community.
By the way, 1966 was also the year Black Panther
first appeared in Marvel comics.
In Coogler's film, as we learn from Zuri,
Killmonger's father N'Jobu experienced discrimination
in Oakland and that led him to act against
Wakandan policy by smuggling out vibranium
in an effort to fight back.
When Killmonger takes over as ruler of Wakanda,
he declares that the sun will "never set on
the Wakandan empire", echoing the phrase used
to describe the former Spanish and British
Empires, which were so large it was said always
to be daytime somewhere.
Killmonger further overturns Wakandan traditions
when he orders the burning of the heart-shaped
herb, and director Ryan Coogler reflects Killmonger's
revolution and the fact he is turning how
Wakanda operates completely on its head by
having the camera revolve 180 degrees from
an upside-down position as the new king enters
the throne room.
Michael B. Jordan has said of Killmonger that,
"He is always ten steps ahead.
He's very patient.
That's a very dangerous attribute to have
as a villain because he's going to sit and
wait, and he's going to plan and calculate
every move."
Killmonger gained both tactical and military
skills on combat missions in countries such
as Afghanistan and Iraq, and he appears to
kill his girlfriend and then also Klaue, who
he'd been collaborating with, seemingly without
hesitation when he deemed it necessary to
getting into Wakanda.
Killmonger is incredibly effective and ruthless
in carrying out his plan to take over the
nation.
Yet, despite his extremes, you can empathise
with his grievances.
In short, he's an incredible antagonist.
And although, ultimately, Killmonger fails
to complete his plans, the fact that T'Challa
was deeply affected by the experiences of
N'Jobu and Killmonger and the actions of T'Chaka
means that other kids from Oakland can now
believe in Wakanda and its incredible technological
advances without thinking it's just a fairy
tale.
It really is good to see Marvel developing
their villains better in recent movies and,
Michael B. Jordan is such a fantastic actor
who brought so much to this film that it's
a real shame to think he won't be returning,
but Killmonger did have a great arc.
The other great secondary villain in the movie
was Ulysses Klaue, played in a brilliantly
unhinged and humorous way by Andy Serkis,
and again, it's a pity his character is dead.
Of course, these are comic book movies, so
technically any character can still come back
from the dead.
In fact, there is one Marvel villain I do
think could make a stunning return in the
MCU for a very good reason, and that's a certain
green goddess and you can check out my theory
on why I think we'll see her again right here.
An important recommendation that T'Challa
followed from his father was to surround himself
with good people and it was his little sister
Shuri who played a huge role in helping him
take back the throne.
She and Nakia are extremely loyal to T'Challa
though both of them have a rebellious streak
and they encourage the young king to push
beyond the status quo.
Shuri herself is constantly pushing herself
to another level, actively developing and
improving her tech; indeed, as she told her
brother, "just because it works, doesn't mean
it can't be improved."
In fact, that's something I think T'Challa
takes on board in opening up Wakanda.
And it was great to see Shuri so excited in
the final scene when her brother announced
she was going to lead the Wakandan technology
exchange with the rest of the world.
I can't wait to see what tech she gets to
develop in Avengers: Infinity War and I'd
love to see her meet Tony Stark at some point
as I think their banter and talk about her
amazing inventions could be fantastic.
There's also the possibility she could don
a Black Panther suit of her own in the future
and there's a hint at that via the toothed
neckpiece she wears in some scenes in the
film.
By the way, I think it's interesting that
the new Wakandan centre will be established
in Oakland because the next Marvel movie after
Avengers: Infinity War is Ant-Man And The
Wasp, which is set in San Francisco and, geographically,
Oakland is just across the bay.
In fact, the Oakland Bay Bridge made an appearance
in the first Ant-Man And The Wasp trailer,
and I wonder whether there's a chance we could
see Black Panther or some Wakandan characters
cross over into that movie later this year?
Another thing T'Challa achieves by the end
of the film is a sort of repairing of relations
with the Jabari tribe, whose leader M'Baku
does not take kindly to his request that they
join him against Killmonger as previous kings
have not bothered to visit them in centuries.
T'Challa spared M'Baku's life during their
ritual combat for the throne, but M'Baku already
repaid that debt when he helped save T'Challa
after Killmonger flung him off the side of
a mountain.
Still, in the end, M'Baku and his people do
rally to T'Challa's cause of saving Wakanda
from Killmonger, because they realise, as
Black Panther explained, that this affects
everyone.
And in doing this M'Baku and his tribe have
a huge impact on the final battle.
And talking of the final battle, the Dora
Milaje also play a key role with Okoye literally
bringing a rhino to a standstill by fearlessly
confronting her love W'Kabi as soon as she
realises that Killmonger is not the rightful
king.
She's an incredible fighter, as are her Dora
Milaje sisters, and I can't wait to see more
of them on screen.
Now, I spoke about how important the final
scene is in showing how T'Challa is transforming
and opening up Wakandan society to the wider
world.
And this could have a big effect on the rest
of the MCU which we see the beginnings of
when T'Challa addresses the United Nations
in the first end-credits scene.
And I've actually got a separate video with
a full breakdown of that scene plus the final
stinger scene with Bucky and what it all means
for Avengers: Infinity War, and you can watch
that by tapping right up here, or clicking
the link in the video description below.
So, were you impressed by Black Panther's
first solo movie and are you hyped to see
more of Wakanda in a sequel and in Avengers:
Infinity War?
And which were your favourite characters in
the movie?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to also subscribe to
enter my Black Panther giveaway!
The winner of my Deadpool 2 giveaway is on
screen right now, so if that's you make sure
you private message me with your details.
I really appreciate all your support so if
you enjoyed this do hit the like button and
share the video.
And why not join the notification squad by
clicking the bell for all my new Black Panther
and other videos coming very shortly?!
Also tap any of the links here to check out
more videos you might like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!